local Republican actually kind of cool
Thomas Massie a libertarian congressman
from Kentucky is ready to shake things
up on the House floor elected in 2012
Massie an MIT grad with a successful
tech company under his belt is a
character to say the least not only does
nasty ona Tesla and live off the grid on
a self-sustained cattle farm he stands
for some pretty progressive ideas the
congressman is against national
surveillance wants to repeal the Patriot
Act it's for industrial hemp and has
voted against John Boehner for Speaker
of the House not once but twice Massie
claims he's no superhero instead he's
just an ideologue saying if something I
care about lines up with something a
Democrat cares about there's nothing
that gets in the way of us working
together all right so the guy is off the
grid he's down with hemp he doesn't like
the NSA he's not a fan of Boehner there
was the establishment Republicans guy
actually seems kind of cool could either
one of you guys ever vote Republican I
mean I could vote Republican I agree
with his ideal a viewpoint of supporting
the cause that belief the law and not
the not being partisan but this guy just
because he owns a Tesla and like lives
has solar I'm just very impressed with
it is like yeah I like Tesla's too but
he also supported the Defense of
Marriage Act he is pro-life he's for
offshore drilling I mean there's a lot
of very Republican things that are still
going on that Trump him being just like
environmentally sound yeah so you could
vote Republican just not this guy I mean
I could if his his or her viewpoints
lined up with mine but so far it hasn't
happened yeah you know what do you think
about this hemp off the great that's a
driver I think you're giving too much
credit to being off the grid there's a
lot of people who live off the grid who
are like not cool and I'm totally crazy
right I really of like they're really
stoned like people who are like way off
the grid who are paranoid yeah and like
like I don't know if I mean he seems
cool enough yeah kind of not based on
everything else he believes in but like
I don't know if he's actually chill or
just like really scared of the
government like no gonna say I live on
my own I'm like I'm like really high all
the time
up and now we don't know that he smoked
you he just wants him ok I'll happy
could build a rope herido this guy cool
my mind is born by this story because I
just don't get what makes that guy also
please reference back the photo of him
really that guy looks awesome like I
want to be like him like no you know I'm
not judging a book by it's cover there
but even when I opened the book and read
some pages I wasn't super stuff done am
I was right desert really into the Tesla
I just really like the Tesla I like the
idea of off the grid but actually gonna
backtrack a little bit cuz I think you
are right like when I think of someone
off the grid I think of like this sort
of grungy like kind of dirty guy that
has to like do [ __ ] but that guy he does
I think i mighta forlan but I don't
wanna make the question look he's really
sued and you know I think I don't think
I'll the gun stockpile like waiting for
the government to come to his guns away
and you're just like ready right what
does it tell you about somebody that
would want to be off the grid yet also
be a politician like you wanted that a
politician is the most invasive thing
it's like seeing right what it's like CH
once be a pop star but like no one know
what she looks like ah that's slightly
going over my head but I feel like it's
a good rep she's a pop star she's facing
the other way when she performs or she
covers her face entirely yeah yeah she
wants that be a pop star and performed
but like not have the celebrity aspect
of it right said so she goes out but she
will cover her face is yeah well she can
like not be recommended see I think fun
guys yeah yeah but she's doing it like
with a deliberate message of like I
don't want to have to do a celebrity
culture but I don't think he's doing it
like I don't want to deal with politics
I think he's like possibly like watching
illegal pornography like a lot so he's
off the or something like that maybe
that's what we don't use electricity and
internet into Wi-Fi is I'm like you know
I'm saying I think we just agree he's on
the dark guy he can just get like a hot
spot nothing like from a satellite I'm
just saying something is fishy with this
because his actual politics are not in
any way liberal really they're not so
does the whole to party thing seemed
completely crazy to you like when I saw
the story the thing that I actually saw
it on BuzzFeed and the thing that seemed
interesting to me was that it was a
Republican that was a little bit
different and that just seems so silly
like that anyone does anyone either one
of you do identify as a Democrat than or
like doesn't the label stuff just see my
videos I identify I'm a
or Democrat because I want to be able to
vote in the primaries and that's pretty
much it but I mean other than that I I
welcome people to change my viewpoints
on other and other parties I really look
forward to it but if owning a Tesla is
going to separate me from the pack like
what the hell this just seems like a bit
big as yessuh I don't identifies as
anything based on them you know for work
reasons I'm very private hopefully / you
could read my tweets and probably figure
it out like I'll just say for now you
know it's it I I do i do think that the
focus kind ideas and not the party is
interesting but as you said if you
better than a tesla and like some weird
paranoid off the grid stuff all right
I'm you guys have brought me back here
people I'm coming back and you know what
if you want a vote for a pot smoker who
owns a Tesla you could vote for my
friend roseanne barr who did run for
president has a great documentary that
you should also check out anyway what do
you think on this story a republican off
the grid does it make any sense let us
know in the comments right down